yes summer 2015 it looks like it's off
to a pretty solid start just in the
month of May with a month pull often
Imams Mad Max fury road so Mad Max fury
road is the fourth Mad Max movie in the
George Miller Mad Max movies the last
one which was Beyond Thunderdome came
out 30 years ago now is like a well I
guess there's more to tell so let's make
a new Mad Max movie and this one Tom
Hardy plays Mad Max it's a pretty simple
premise for the movie it's an escort
mission from a videogame you got to get
this huge truck from point A to point B
long stretch of post-apocalyptic desert
road and while they're doing that leets
of crazies and maniacs are gonna try to
kill them and that's Mad Max fury road
now this movie's crazy I'm not gonna lie
to you it's just out of its mind it's
George Miller's Mad Max doing George
Miller Mad Max things with a bigger
budget at a point you look at it you're
like this movie's like a cartoon version
of it's crazy post-apocalyptic sell
difference between when this movie does
it in a lot of other movies there's a
lot of other movies it doesn't make any
sense in this movie completely makes
sense you're like yeah we're half past
the precipice of madness I guess people
aren't saying anymore [ __ ] max is kind
of crazy
I imagine if humanity was left to its
own devices to find itself it would be
at least this crazy now getting right
into the action because this movie is
pretty much built for the action the
action in this movie is crazy not only
is it impressive not only is it high
octane but it's practical George Miller
built this movie on practical special
effects not visual effects yet this
green screen in this movie there are
visual effects when it calls for it but
generally speaking when cars are
flipping and blowing up that's a car
flipping and blowing up it's artillery
it's pyro it's something real and we're
all were a lot of things are CGI you
just appreciate that stuff more but the
funny thing is I don't know why this
movies called Mad Max because Charlize
Theron is actually the badass in this
movie this is Charlize Theron movie
should be called for her name's Furioso
she should be called furiosa Road and
Mad Max yeah he's in this movie - Mad
Max is the second biggest badass in this
movie in the third most interesting
character not only Charlize Theron
character interesting but Nicolas Holt's
character interesting too because up to
this point we've only just seen these
crazies be crazier like yeah just fleets
of crazies and we know they're the bad
guy
as in Max's the good guys we're gonna
root for max against the crazies crazy
crazy crazy people in Mad Max are crazy
but Nikolas Holtz character brings an
element of humanity to that you're like
oh what's going through their mind oh
[ __ ] they have feelings
that's weird didn't know that for 30
years and this movie has a menacing bad
guy too
who looks like the father of sweet tooth
from twisted metal in fact given the
setting and the action and the cars and
the racing and the carnage in this movie
I'm pretty sure it is the father of
sweet tooth from twisted metal you take
the cover art of twisted metal and you
just put Mad Max fury road on it it'd be
a pretty applicable poster for this
movie the bummer is the fact that this
movie is ultimately a big action
sequence all wrapped up into two hours
we've got a lot of character development
among the characters in this movie there
are a couple of moments of heart a few
moments of development that's for sure
it doesn't stick and that's not what you
remember you watch this movie for the
action you walk out going yeah the
action was pretty friggin sweet which is
why you should watch the movie and the
movie knows that and it knows what it is
and it plays up what it is if you
haven't enjoyed any of the Mad Max
movies before you're just going into
this movie to critique the [ __ ] out of
it or it'll walk out being like yeah
movies stupid I didn't like it but if
you want to see a post-apocalyptic movie
with a two-hour action sequence we'll
say one and a half will round down Mad
Max fury road is definitely worth
watching and certainly worth buying on
blu-ray perfect party movie to have some
friends over see some death destruction
carnage cars explosions Lord death more
destruction or carnage right guys so Mad
Max fury road have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
of the madness comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more